Billie Jean King said this movie isn't
really about tennis it's about social
change how would you describe it in the
exact same way I think what makes it so
interesting as much fun as tennis is or
sports movies are I think really the the
ultimate message of the battle of the
sexes itself was about equality and you
know women were not even remotely being
paid equally in this sport and obviously
women are not being paid equally to this
day in many industries why is this why
do you think that is why do you think so
many years later that's still the
headlines and still a conversation I
mean I just think it's been you know
sometimes progress takes two takes up a
much longer time than we think it will
and that's you know it's not just
between the sexes but it's been I mean
like it's on so many levels equality
it's incredibly important and and it's
good that the conversation is happening
and that people are able to you know
speak out and and move it forward but
yeah there still is such a long way to
go in terms of you know all all equality
that all human beings deserve to be
treated and respected equally no matter
what do you ever feel that those things
on your shoulders with equal pain and
being marginalized in that from that
standpoint I think it's on everybody's
shoulders I think that everybody you
know that if that's happening in our
world and obviously it's at such a
boiling point there's so much on the
surface right now in at least in our
country there's certainly a lot that's
you know being is threatened yeah so
it's I think a time for everyone a lot
of people a lot of my friends a lot of
you know people that I talk to feel very
galvanized to be you know even if you
didn't speak out before about about
these issues it's it's really hard not
to so I don't know that I feel any more
pressure than anybody that I know feels
to to do as much as we can and I'm still
learning the how to use my voice or and
how it's you
to be effective in that way but I think
it's so important for all of us how is
it meeting Billie Jean King House
incredible yeah yeah
so it's also really crazy to meet her
under the under the guise like the there
was a pretense to like you know that so
it's it was a I think a little
nerve-wracking I own it on a different
level just like hi what is it feel like
what a house her mouth moving how is she
moving you know it's it was a it was
wild but she could not be more you know
just she's like a ball of energy she's
just like this hugely warm and um
incredible presence in her is just I
mean she's just amazing so how's your
tennis game it's super great like
professional definitely number one in
the world level thank you for asking